i think to be successfully comes down to
or one of the main factors
it is kind of a large dose of
individuality um
i think every everyone can bring various
different kind of strengths to the table
and it's knowing how to leverage those
strengths to kind of your advantage
it's kind of a combination of playing to
your strengths but doing the other stuff
anyway
probably just tell him to believe in the
trust in the process
and follow the process um you know it's
it's really easy
to to hear things sometimes but not
listen um
and second that probably the best advice
i could give myself would be not to
spend the commission until i receive it
just because because yeah you're always
living kind of a couple of paychecks in
advance going away i'm gonna have a big
month
and yeah that can come back to bite you
if you've not been for her and obviously
something
something adverse has happened as a
result of things you going to
recruitment company
your first day you've got your own mugs
out there you've got your laptop's setup
you've got your email account all done
all your logins are sorted and you know
that's all taken care of and brilliant
and we're logging here i'm going to
get to work but obviously it's the it's
the negotiating behind that
it's all the invoicing it's it's praying
to god that people pay you on time the
three foot in the four months or so that
i've been
a business owner um it has been an
absolute baptism of fire
um i've had to think on my feet a lot
quicker than i have done in the past
i've had to learn very quickly
and i've had to adjust